what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another a Song of Ice and Fire
video if you have been watching my
channel very recently then you would
know I am making a video on each chapter
from each book my most recent video was
about bran Starks first chapter and in
that video I went over some of the
connections between House Stark and the
White Walkers what I want to do now is
dive a little deeper into that subject I
happen to believe there is a significant
amount of evidence for this scattered
throughout the book series the White
Walkers and House Stark have been
connected to one another since of the
very beginning their connection began
roughly 8,000 years ago during the long
night when the White Walkers were
created and how Stark was founded as I
have said before I do not think this is
a coincidence whatsoever so let's go
through some of the evidence that has
been laid out for us in the books now
based on what we know from one of old
main stories this all started thousands
and thousands of years ago when a
Winterfell that was cold and hard and
endless beyond all memory of man there
came a night that lasted a generation in
Kings shivered and died in their castles
even as the swineherds in their hovels
woman smothered their children rather
than see them starve and cried and felt
the tears freeze on their cheeks in that
darkness the others came for the first
time she said as her needles went
click-click-click they were cold things
dead things that hated iron and fire and
the touch of the Sun and every creature
with hot blood in its veins so as you
can see old nan says thousands and
thousands of years ago a Winterfell
that's a very interesting choice of
words if you ask me now the only reason
why this winter fell was because the
White Walkers invaded Westeros they
brought the winter with them causing the
long night they slaughtered everything
and everyone as they went further and
further south how the long night
actually ended as a matter of legend in
the north they tell of alas hero who
sought out the children of the forest
his companions abandoning him are dying
one by one as they faced ravenous giants
cold servants and the others themselves
alone he finally did reach the children
the efforts of the White Walkers thanks
to the children the first men of the
Nights Watch banded together and were
able to fight and win the battle for the
dawn the last battle that broke the
endless winter and sent the others
fleeing to the icy north now we don't
have a lot of information on this event
but what we do know is the White Walkers
brought the long night when they invaded
Westeros then a legendary figure known
as the last hero found that children of
the forest he eventually joined forces
with the first men of the Nights Watch
and together they were able to send the
White Walkers back into the far north
now this is speculation but I happen to
think the last hero was one of the first
members of House Stark along with
Brandon the Builder this is also when
House Stark began naming their house
sword ice and I believe this also
symbolizes their defeat over the White
Walkers the stark sword that we are
introduced to is only 400 years old but
the Neyman head was older still a legacy
from the Age of Heroes when the Starks
were kings of the north the long night
happened during the Age of Heroes and I
think this is when the Starks began
using that name for their swords in one
of Sam's chapters we learned something
very interesting it says I found one
account of the long night that spoke at
the last hero slaying others with a
blade of dragon steel supposedly they
could not stand against it after the
lycée Burroughs sent the White Walkers
fleeing back into the north
I believe he gave his sword the name ice
to represent his victory over the White
Walkers this would also be a reminder
that this is the kind of blade you have
to have to defeat them that's why the
Starks continued to name their house
sword ice even after all these years but
a lot of this information had been
forgotten the name of their sword ice as
well as their house words winter is
coming
is all connected to the White Walkers
after the White Walkers were defeated
and sent north this is when Brandon the
Builder made the wall and Winterfell in
hopes of stopping the White Walkers from
ever coming back south again the
greatest castle of the north is
Winterfell the seat of the Starks since
the dawn age legend says Brandon the
Builder raised Winterfell after the
generation long winter known as the long
night to become the stronghold
his descendants the kings of winter so
as you can see the Starks castle was
built immediately after the long night
ended and this was for a few different
reasons in my opinion first let's look
at the name of the castle Winterfell I
think it was given this name as a
reminder of what happened during the
long night remember what old nan said
thousands and thousands of years ago a
Winterfell when the White Walkers
invaded Westeros although the White
Walkers were defeated they were still
alive in the far north all it says is
the last hero and the first men of the
Nights Watch sent them fleeing into the
icy north the White Walkers never went
extinct they knew the White Walkers
could always come back one day that's
why Brandon the Builder had that giant
wall constructed to stop them from
invading again but just in case they
ever made it south again they needed a
second line of defense this is why I
think he made Winterfell next and they
gave it that name to symbolize this
horrific event it was a reminder the
same as the Starks House words winter is
coming
these names and phrases were to remind
the Starks of what was in the far north
I believe this is also why a stark must
remain in Winterfell for when and if the
White Walkers ever resurfaced the last
hero who I believe was one of the first
members of House Stark was able to
defeat them so I think they thought they
would need another Stark to defeat them
again I mean it's no coincidence that
the Starks were set up as the family to
face off against them in the current
story the children of the forest and
bloodraven were watching over bran stark
and Jon Snow because they knew it would
have to be one of the members from this
ancient house that defeats them again
this is one of the reasons why they were
known as the kings of winter they are
from a special bloodline that was able
to go face-to-face with the White
Walkers and when also as I have said
before I believe Winterfell was built in
this exact location because this is
where the first night king or king of
winter was defeated there are a few
things said in the books that let us
know this is a very special location we
learned that the crypts of Winterfell
were made first and they just so happen
to be sitting right above some natural
Hot Springs there
is why the inside of the castle is able
to stay fairly warm even during the
winter I think they also chose this
location because of what they wanted to
bury down inside of those crypts beneath
Winterfell there is some evidence in the
books that indicates there are White
Walkers or some version of A Knight's
king or Knights Queen locked up down
there
there are several references in the
books that say the statues and the
crypts have eyes made of ice another
direct connection to the White Walkers
in the opening scene of the series we
meet the White Walkers when three men of
the Nights Watch go out beyond the wall
to find some wildling Raiders when well
seized one of the White Walkers he
notices their eyes are blue but they are
deeper and bluer than any human eyes
they were a blue that burned like ice we
learn about the kings of winter having
eyes of ice when Ned Stark goes down
into the crypts of Winterfell when Ned
is walking down there it says he was
walking through the crypts beneath
Winterfell as he had walked a thousand
times before
the kings of winter watched him with
eyes of ice Jon Snow also has dreams
where the dead men stumble out of their
graves beneath the castle
John is deathly afraid of what he might
find down there it says John dreamed he
was wandering the empty Castle searching
for his father descending into the
crypts only this time he had gone
further than before in the dark he'd
heard the scrape of stone on stone when
he turned he saw that the vaults were
opening one after the other as the dead
Kings came stumbling from their cold
black graves now I know some of you
might be asking yourself what makes you
think there are White Walkers or a
night's king locked up down there well
let me show you something else that I
find to be very interesting from the
books when Ned Stark is down below the
castle it also says this by ancient
custom an iron longsword had been laid
across the lap of each who had been Lord
of Winterfell to keep the vengeful
spirits in their crypts that sounds very
ominous to me it sounds like the Starks
were wanting to keep the vengeful
spirits locked up forever it says in
order to keep the spirits locked up they
have to keep iron longswords laning
across the laps of the statues I find it
very interesting that they were using
iron swords because of something
old man said do you remember what she
said about the White Walkers and the
things that they did not like old man
said the White Walkers were cold things
dead things that hated iron and fire and
the touch of the Sun and every creature
with hot blood in its veins so if the
White Walkers are these vengeful spirits
beneath Winterfell what would you use to
keep them locked up inside well since
they hate iron you would most likely lay
an iron longsword across the laps of
each of the statues that would be one of
the ways you could stop them from
getting out now you might be wondering
when would they have locked up a white
Walker or Knights King down there is
there any evidence for that well yes in
one of Davos whose chapters we learn
about a very interesting member of House
Stark who lived many many years ago this
is also when we hear another reference
of a winter that fell this is what it
says in his chapter then a long winter
fell said sir Barda miss the white knife
froze hard and even the Firth was icing
up the winds came howling from the north
and drove them slavers inside to huddle
round their fires and while they warmed
themselves the new king come down on
them Brandon Stark this was edrick Snow
beards great-grandson him that men
called ice eyes he took the Wolf's den
back stripped the slavers naked and gave
them to the slaves he'd found chained up
in the dungeons it said they hung their
entrails and the branches of the Hart
tree as an offering to the gods
the old gods not these new ones from the
south you're seven don't know winter and
winter don't know them no I don't know
about you but this brain Dan i sighs
sounds like he could have been some form
of a white Walker or night's king
whenever we hear that a winter fell we
hear about someone or something coming
down from the north with eyes of ice
very similar to the long night this
Brandon stark also seemed to bring some
bad weather with him
it says the white knife river froze hard
and even the Firth was icing up the
winds came howling from the north when
Brandon ice eyes showed up to deliver
his justice since he was a king in the
north or a king of winter he is most
likely down in the crypts beneath
Winterfell in his eyes are
haunting the castle till this day but
once again the best evidence comes from
little old nan the one and only time a
night's king is actually referenced in
the books we learned that he was a stark
of Winterfell who had to be slain by his
own brother the king in the north
I happen to believe the bodies of this
Nights King as well as his Knights Queen
were brought back to Winterfell to be
locked up below the castle and their
crypts now if there are any vengeful
spirits below Winterfell I believe it
would be that of this Brandon Stark the
thirteenth Lord Commander of the Nights
Watch let's have a look at what old nan
says so I can show you exactly what I
mean
old name says he had been the 13th man
to lead the Nights Watch a warrior who
knew no fear and that was the fault in
him she would add for all men must no
fear a woman was his downfall
a woman glimpse from atop the wall with
skin as white as the moon and eyes like
blue stars fearing nothing he chased her
and caught her and loved her though her
skin was cold as ice and when he gave
his seed to her he gave his soul as well
he brought her back to the Nightfort and
proclaimed her acquaintance elf her king
for 13 years they had ruled nights king
in his corpse queen until finally the
stark of Winterfell in German of the
wildlings had joined to free the watch
from bondage after his fall when it was
found out he had been sacrificing to the
others all records of knights King had
been destroyed his very name forbidden
so here we learned there was a main of
the Nights Watch who loved the woman
that sounded much like a white Walker
herself they were together for 13 years
at the night for and it is said they
were making sacrifices to the white
walkers beyond the wall I believe they
were sacrificing their own children now
actually think about that for a second
if this night's King was a stark like
old name says and he was sleeping with a
white Walker Nights Queen that means
those babies they were sacrificing to
the others had stark blood
therefore there are white walkers beyond
the wall who are half stark remember
this is referenced in bran Starks a very
first chapter when he thinks about old
nan stories he remembers she would say
wildling woman would sleep with the
White Walkers creating these half human
half white Walker children but all of
that is just the setup for this massive
revelation not only were the wildlings
doing that but so is a Stark a member of
the family who has been battling these
White Walkers since they first invaded
Westeros during the long night we have
always seen the Starks as the good guys
but now we know they are somewhat
responsible for keeping the White
Walkers alive I think this is absolutely
fascinating now let me just finish what
it says during old Nan's story
old nan also said some say he was a
Bolton old nan would always end some say
a Magna out of skagos some say umber
Flint or nori some would have you think
he was a wood foot from them who ruled
Bear Island before the iron men came he
never was he was a Stark the brother of
the man who brought him down he was a
stark of Winterfell and who can say
mayhaps his name was Brandon mayhaps he
slept in this very bed in this very room
now what do you think happened to their
bodies it says when the stark and
Winterfell found out his own brother was
making sacrifices to the White Walkers
he made sure all records of the Nights
King had been destroyed and his very
name forbidden I would bet that his
brother brought him back home but locked
him up in the crypts deep beneath
Winterfell I would bet that this is one
of those vengeful spirits and Ned is
hoping never comes out again this is why
there are iron long swords laying across
their laps because we know the others
hated iron and that would certainly keep
them from rising up again but old Ned
Stark isn't so sure anymore
those iron swords are beginning to rust
away remember what it says in its
chapter by ancient custom an iron
longsword had been laid across the lap
of each who had been Lord of Winterfell
to keep the vengeful spirits in their
crypts the oldest had long ago rusted
away to nothing
leaving only a few red stains where the
metal had rested on stone
Ned wondered if that meant those ghosts
were free to roam the castle now he was
hoping not
[Music]
[Music]
you